let's start today with what is more
horrible right-wing news out of Italy
where Italy is Shifting dramatically to
the right as the Associated Press
reports rewarding Maloney's party now
you may say anything Maloney wait you're
talking about Christopher Maloney the
guy from Law and Order no no no no it
has nothing to do with that let me tell
you what's going on in Italy uh the AP
reports a party with neo-fascist roots
the brothers of Italy won the most votes
in Italy's national elections looking
set to deliver the country's first
far-right-led government since World War
II and make its leader Georgia Maloney
Italy's first woman Premier near final
results showed Monday
Italy's lurched to the far right shifts
Europe's geopolitical reality placing a
Euro skeptic party in position to lead a
founding member of the EU and its third
largest economy right-wing leaders
across Europe immediately hailed
Maloney's Victory and her party's
meteoric rise ascending an historic
message to Brussels also a report from
BBC with a similar assessment and
similar analysis Maloney is widely
expected to form Italy's most right-wing
government since World War II now if
you're interested in the specific
policies that Maloney ran on
um and that her party ran on brothers of
Italy certainly take a look at that it
is a more or less standard package of
this yeah some call it right-wing
nationalism
others say it really is neo-fascist now
why has this been happening in Europe
because we've seen it in Hungary we've
seen the rise of these movements in the
Czech Republic and Poland and in many
different places even some of the more
traditionally left-wing countries like
Sweden have seen elements of this
right-wing nationalism rise the story
that is told by The Defenders you've got
your strong Defenders and your soft
Defenders of this right-wing movement
the story they like to tell is a very
similar story to what those in the U.S
like to tell about Donald Trump which is
these individuals have correctly
identified
economic concerns and they've coalesced
those who feel as though they have been
left behind as open border immigration
has been welcomed and on and on and they
said look here I am actually getting a
message that makes sense which is we
need to be it's simply about being for
the people that are here
it's about being you know in the U.S the
story was
we want a guy who's four Americans not
for China
not for the Mexicans coming in through
the border with just he's for Americans
that's what's great about Trump and it's
a very similar story that they like to
tell about the rise of these movements
Hey listen we finally have someone who's
going to speak up for Italians not
Turkish immigrants or Morocco you know
whatever whatever the country is
depending on where in Europe you are
there's nothing wrong with being for the
French or for the hungarians they're
just it's it's for us it's good that's
the story that's told however
we know that it's not really about those
economic realities and economic concerns
because we have counter examples you
look two really good examples are the
Czech Republic and Poland
in the Czech Republic in Poland there
has been an improving economic situation
by basically every measure over recent
years and yet support for this
right-wing nationalist
neo-fascist movement has grown in the
Czech Republic and in Poland over those
years so there's two possibilities one
possibility is
even though the economy has been
improving
a lot of people don't realize that and
so they say no we need these right-wing
nationalists now that happens in the
United States people just ignorant of
the reality I mean look at right now in
the United States despite some
indicators not being so good like
inflation we are close to Full
Employment and most economic indicators
are actually quite solid you could have
the same thing in Europe the economy is
improving people don't believe it is so
then they go we need a neo-fascist
that's one possibility second
possibility is it's not really about the
economic stuff and in the United States
under Trump
some people felt that it was the
populist economic message that attracted
them to Trump but we know it was more
than that we know it was if not creating
racism and xenophobia certainly
welcoming it and saying you can all be
part of this movement and so they found
a home with Trump all of these things
were really what was going on and so
propaganda is a huge part of it
um fear is a big part of it we know that
making people afraid leads them to
reactionary political beliefs when
people become fearful they reflexively
say well let's do something about that
fear
uh much like if you were convinced that
there was a really high risk of for
example a home invasion in your
neighborhood you would in a reactionary
way be willing to do all sorts of things
that maybe when you're clear-headed you
wouldn't be willing to do whether it's
buying all sorts of guns or booby
trapping or whatever right I mean you
get the idea fear gets us to act in ways
we would not normally act and so fear
about immigrants from Northern Africa
has been a big factor in Europe Us
Versus Them ideology the European union
doesn't have our best interest in mind
and they're going you know it's similar
to Trump stuff right NATO NATO it
doesn't have our best interest in mind
these coalitions are bad nafta's bad all
this stuff similar sort of sort of idea
so where we end up
is with the first presumably assuming in
the next few hours everything goes as as
it is expected to go
the most right-wing government in Italy
dating all the way back to World War II
scary stuff and we're going to continue
following this right word rightward
trend big news out of the January 6th
committee the house January 6th
committee investigating the Trump riots
will have their next session after kind
of a summer break on Wednesday and I
will try to cover that live schedule
permitting the big news and Business
Insider has a good article explaining
what's going on January 6th committee
members say they believe Trump was
responsible for the riot and the panel
might unanimously refer Trump for
prosecution this would be a really big
deal it doesn't mean he would be
prosecuted and if he were it doesn't
mean he would be convicted and if he
were it doesn't mean he would go to
prison but let's just start where we are
the highlights from this Business
Insider report January 6 committee
members Schiff and Cheney spoke about
the capital Riot investigation on Sunday
they said they both believed Donald
Trump committed wrongdoing but they said
the panel will give a unanimous verdict
either way when it decides whether to
refer Donald Trump for prosecution so at
the tail end of this uh committee and
the series of hearings
the committee members will vote and they
will say are we referring Trump for
criminal prosecution or not and what
Schiff and Cheney are saying is it will
be a unanimous verdict we won't come out
with a split verdict we will all decide
much like a jury
um Schiff said he will make the decision
his decision aligned with the rest of
the committee so that they act
unanimously we operate with a high
degree of consensus and unanimity so
there's a couple interesting things here
that I want to discuss and how much we
talk about this ahead of the actual
decision it's going to be limited
because it's just going to be a matter
of waiting and seeing this is less about
whether Donald Trump actually ends up in
prison again I do not believe Trump will
end up in prison I think even if you go
to the end of the rainbow to speak
metaphorically
to the conclusion to all of these in
criminal investigations even in the
event of a criminal conviction with a
sentence
as a former president Trump will serve
it out in one of his Resorts it's just
he's not going to end up in prison
and for me this is actually less about
whether he even is given any prison time
that's like 10 steps away this is more
about another criminal problem for Trump
as he considers running for 2024 and
will it impede him from carrying out
such a campaign we already know that
Donald Trump has been sued and
criminally referred in New York by the
Attorney General Leticia James we talked
about that last week we know that as a
result of the FBI search warrant served
at Mar-A-Lago
that is likely a criminal investigation
that is moving well ahead and rather
quickly that's another legal problem we
know about what's going on in Georgia
where Donald Trump remember he needed I
need 11 000 votes give me a break a
probable
um uh wrongdoing there potentially
charges come so the question is now with
the addition
um of a potential criminal referral from
the January 6 committee is this just
going to muck up his trying to run in
2024. now I get it many of you are like
oh David come on six years of this and
nothing it's but bombshell after
bombshell
and yet nothing as we continue to see
evidence of Trump's wrongdoing I'm with
you I'm with you and if I had to issue a
defense for why we should remain
cautiously optimistic and again I'm not
even sure that we should but if I wanted
to make that case the four years Trump
was in office he was protected to some
degree by his own Attorneys General he
had a completely corrupt in his pocket
Republican party who even if they didn't
love Trump they weren't going to say
much about it publicly other than the
rare handful of folks like you know Mitt
Romney and this ridiculous you know some
of them call it a rule it's really sort
of like a uh what a tradition I don't
even know where the Department of
Justice doesn't indict sitting
presidents and some Republicans arguing
the Department of Justice really
shouldn't even investigate sitting
president so that's all gone now so now
what Trump is dependent on or Reliant
upon is can can corrupt judges save him
and the truth is
there could have been a federal Trump
indictment anytime since January for the
Mueller probe if they wanted to do that
a January of 2021 but they haven't he's
no longer a sitting president the
evidence is all still available so I
share everyone's sort of skepticism but
I try to maintain some degree of
cautious optimism and in the next three
months particularly I mean we're only
six five and a half six weeks away from
the uh six weeks from the midterms there
is the belief that after that there may
be action but I I'm with you guys you
know I'm I'm not naively wide-eyed and
bushy-tailed uh holding my breath for
these indictments they clearly should
come but whether they will we will find
out let me know what you expect find me
on Twitter at dpacman after the break
I'm actually going to have for you some
positive examples of how Democrats need
to be talking about the tomfoolery of
the Republican Party stay with us
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
folks memberships are available but
they're running low grab yourself a
membership at joinpakman.com it is the
number one way to support the work we do
every time a child or an adult gets a
membership Alex Jones cries a little bit
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else it makes money find
themselves as bad imagine that every
single one of these memberships
irritates conspiracy theorist Alex Jones
just a teeny tiny bit if only he could
monetize with valuable bonus content
rather than the stuff he sells on his
store okay join pacman.com is the place
to sign up I've got some great video to
play for you here
this is video of how democrats should be
addressing
so much of the nonsense being done by
Republicans both of these Crypt Clips
are from Democratic governor Gavin
Newsom of California now whoa whoa whoa
whoa David sir
I know
you don't have to like Gavin newsom's
politics
or that French Laundry covet dinner
during the time of all sorts of shutdown
guidelines okay to recognize that he
gets the tone and the language that
Democrats have to be using now it seems
pretty clear that Newsome is positioning
himself to run for president or for the
Democratic nomination in 2024. great
good for him when we get the full list
of who's running I will evaluate the
options and tell you who I support right
now the issue is he gets that there
needs to be a certain Edge and
ruthlessness to how Democrats go after
Republicans check out this first clip
this is from a Texas Tribune event over
the weekend where Gavin Newsom is asked
about the busing of migrants that's been
done as a political Stunt by Texas and
California I'm Sorry by Texas and
Florida
um and he morally flip frames the entire
thing correctly take a listen look it's
clear that DeSantis broke the law
question is which law did he break
did he break the laws of his own state
did he break federal law
but one thing he did is he broke with
precedent any precedent of decency and
honor
his lack of character on display he
comes into another state your state to
try to find Pawns in a political game
rounds them up sends them to an island
and then fundraises off it
what does that say about his character
and the character of the Republican
party that celebrated that act of
Cruelty and dehumanization so
I I called it out because I I find it
offensive and disgraceful and I find it
increasingly
normalized now in the Republican party
it's certainly well established here
with Greg Abbott who is apparently
getting more tension on this topic than
Ron DeSantis and he wanted in
and I mean that and that's what's
happened to the Republican party in this
country and that needs to be called out
Iran DeSantis rightfully is being called
out but by not enough people and that's
what concerns me particularly with the
silence the appalling silence within the
Republican party yeah he is completely
right these issues need to be framed
morally as the morally decrepit failures
that they are by the party the
Republicans who claim the Moral Majority
they claim to Value life and the Dignity
of life when you use
immigrants awaiting Asylum adjudication
as political pawns lie to them to get
them on planes not to Boston for jobs as
they were promised but to Martha's
Vineyard as Martha's Vineyard shuts down
for the winter and goes into off season
where there's no jobs on this tiny
Island
to make political points and to score
political points with people's lives
it's not the dignity and respect for
life that they claim to have and Newsome
gets it here's another clip of Newsome
and again you don't have to say this guy
aligns with me on every political view
to recognize that there's a very few
Democrats that are actually talking
about these issues in this way and
framing them in this way Katie Porter is
really good at it Pete boot Edge is
really good at it
there aren't that many people that are
that good at what he is doing and Newsom
here making the point the santis is just
a bully we didn't treat bullies kindly
when I was a kid I like Charlie Chris
and I I I don't like but by the way the
context here is that Newsome is
explaining he donated to Charlie Crist
who's the Democrat running against Ron
DeSantis for governor of Florida
you want to ask what my why is in life I
don't like bullies I don't like people
like to mean people I don't like people
talk down to people I didn't like what
DeSantis said about fauci that he may
disagree with him but to call someone
pejorative terms because they're short
and who the hell raised these guys
what kind of people are they
I mean I know all of us had a you know
sit there and suck it up and take
Trump's demonization but not everybody
has to act like him
I mean literally I I remember growing up
and folks would have their mouths washed
out with soap if they talked like this I
got four kids I don't want these guys
being models the attacking LGBT
community attacking women I mean this
guy's so extreme rape and incest Rhonda
Santos talks about freedom and a young
girl is raped by her father
doesn't have the right to her own body
to make her own decisions sick spare me
Freedom there's no Freedom there's no
choice so yeah I'm standing up as a
human being
got to use those dollars and I hope
others of you send money to send a
message that uh if that's the future of
the damn Republican party this country
is in real trouble and that's what we've
been saying for a long time the left has
the moral High Ground on so many of
these issues the left has the moral High
Ground on the abortion issue the right
likes to claim it for themselves but
what is important is can you articulate
it clearly and many Democrats struggle
to articulate that moral High Ground
clearly and what I like about Newsome is
that he is doing that now we can talk
about who should represent Democrats on
the presidential ticket in 2024 if Joe
Biden doesn't run that's a different
question than is Newsom striking the
right tone and getting down to the Crux
really the kernel of of Truth
fundamental truth here about the
disgusting nature of what the Republican
party has become I believe that he is
now Chris has a very much uphill battle
uh in in Florida and we've looked at the
polling there it doesn't look
particularly good for Charlie Crist but
that's a different question than is this
the language and the tone that democrats
should be using I believe the answer is
yes if you disagree with me or if you
agree with me let me know I want to hear
from you all right making big news over
the weekend is a short video clip in
which Jared Kushner Donald Trump's
son-in-law
attacks or criticizes may be better said
Ron DeSantis is Martha's Vineyard
immigrant stunt now as a reminder this
is the stunt in which Ron DeSantis
sent via plane migrants awaiting Asylum
adjudication in Texas to Martha's
Vineyard a small island off the coast of
Massachusetts lied to them promised jobs
said you're going to Boston you're going
to get expedited a regular normalization
of your Immigration Center all these
different lies lured them there
potentially illegal using these people's
uh lives essentially as political pawns
so a big deal was made of the fact that
Jared Kushner went on Fox News
and he said he was against it he said he
doesn't like what Ron DeSantis did
there's a very specific self-serving
reason why he said this and many of you
already know what it is let's look at
the clip and then discuss I also we have
to remember these are human beings
they're people so seeing them being used
as political pawns one way or the other
is is very uh troubling to me okay
Jared's against it he says these are
people seeing these people use the as
political puns is troubling to me
wow that's that's true I agree with that
right well let's just think of both the
hypocrisy and the real reason for this
number one the hypocrisy is that during
Trump's presidency
he tried to do something very similar he
said uh if there's an interview where
Miles Taylor spoke about this
Trump said let's bus immigrants from the
border
and put him in Democratic cities and
Trump actually wanted to Trump's idea
was let's find the ones that are that
are criminals and bring them to
democratic cities so Trump wanted to do
the exact same thing there's no moral
High Ground here for what Jared Kushner
is saying the reason why Jared Kushner
is saying this is very very simple
in the betting markets Ron DeSantis has
now taken a lead over Donald Trump
in terms of who is expected to be the
Republican Presidential nominee in 2024.
we have seen this fight growing now for
months and months Donald Trump
increasingly was furious with Ron
DeSantis because when Ron DeSantis was
asked about running in 2024 DeSantis
didn't say well I would only consider
running if Trump doesn't want it Trump
is mad at DeSantis because Trump wants
DeSantis on his knees uh praying at the
altar of trump and saying if the orange
fearless leader wants the nomination I
will get out of the way DeSantis hasn't
done that and that has caused anger for
Donald Trump and slowly but surely over
the last year we have seen in the
betting numbers remember this is when
people bet on who they believe will be
the nominee not polling
the betting numbers have shifted more
and more and more away from being in
Trump's favor to the point where now Ron
DeSantis by a small margin is favored to
be the Republican 2024 nominee in the
betting markets this is why Jared
Kushner is taking the opportunity to
attack DeSantis it's not because of an
actual moral conflict here where he
doesn't like what it is that Rhonda
Sanders did because Trump tried to do
the exact same thing that's what this is
about and my hope is that it gets very
very ugly between Trump and DeSantis My
Hope Is that Trump wants the nomination
and that so does the santis and that
they get into a big to do and it just
sabotages them that would really be the
goal you're not going to believe this
next clip this this is just unbelievable
it I expected that it would happen but I
didn't know that it would be John
barasso last week during a whacked
interview with Sean Hannity Donald Trump
talked about telepathic declassification
of documents Donald Trump said during
his interview with Sean Hannity that his
president he could think about
declassifying a document and that
declassifies the document don't believe
me you don't have to here's the video
send it you know there's different
people say different things but as I
understand there doesn't have to be if
you're the president of the United
States you can declassify just by saying
it's Declassified even by thinking about
it because you're sending it to
Mar-A-Lago or to wherever you're sending
it there it is just by thinking about
declassification you can declassify
documents this is absolutely sickening
insane
absurd comical in some weird way well
Republican senator John barrasso went on
ABC's This Week With George
Stephanopoulos yesterday
Stephanopoulos rhetorically asks him
about telepathic declassification
and barasso doesn't even say that's
that's absurd George look at this this
is unbelievable well I want to ask you
about the investigation of Donald
Trump's handling of classified
information even though his lawyers have
provided no evidence that he
Declassified the documents the Trump
said this week that as president he
could declassify documents by thinking
about it do you agree with that
I've not heard that one before George
like I tell you in terms of National
Security folks
he's answering it like it's a real
question
he's answering it like it's a real thing
telepathic declassification commence
we have to always use Extreme Caution
I'm one of the Foreign Relations
Committee we deal with classified
information all of the time and really
and have you ever on that Foreign
Relations Committee
dealt with the telepathic
declassification of documents we're
always very careful I don't know what a
what anything about the rules for when a
president declassifies I mean maybe the
rules allow telepathic declassification
maybe they don't documents and
information
what I do know is what I'd like to see
from a senate standpoint is I'd like to
see the Department of Justice come to us
and show us in a classified setting what
the information is what they've done I
thought this the rate at the former
president's home and now you'll see
Stephanopoulos realize that barrasso's
lost the plot and try to get him back on
track by saying Senator what I said is
absurd never seen anything like that
before clearly and it's because so I
want to get a briefing so that we can
then be informed to see what actually
happened here that that was a rhetorical
question you know that a president can't
declassify documents by thinking about
it why can't you say so
yeah I don't think a president can
declassify documents by saying so by
thinking about it why does it by saying
so no by thinking about it what is wrong
with this guy is this guy so under the
thumb of trumpism that he can't just
come out and say George of course you
can't think about documents and
declassify them of course of course that
first and foremost I also am concerned
about how the search warrant was
approved oh okay well now we have a
conversation to talk about but 60
seconds about well listen you know we
should figure out what the documents are
and then determine what are the methods
we're talking about telepathically
Declassified declassifying documents
here oh yeah no you can't do that you
know that's true I guess you can't do
that these people are off the deep end
and if you think this is bad just wait
until you see what I have coming up
after the break remember you can find
all of these clips that we play on the
show on our Instagram search David
packman show on Instagram
if you value what we do at the David
Pacman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright
many of you knew this was coming even
right wing Drudge Report is Raising
questions about Trump dementia after a
completely deranged and outrageous
speech in Wilmington North Carolina over
the weekend Drudge Report after Trump's
completely disassembled speech saying
dementing done dementing Dawn yes this
has now gone mainstream Donald Trump
holding a so-called rally in Wilmington
North Carolina over the weekend which we
covered Live on YouTube twitch and
Facebook at the rally Trump didn't make
any sense and you absolutely have to see
some of the things that took place
Donald Trump denied being a terrorist at
the event
understand that a former president is
denying being a terrorist that is not
normal in the United States 2 falsely
label Mega make America great again Mega
remember what you know they say mega
mega mega they don't want to say what it
means it means make America great again
Uncle Sam
supporters as they want to call us
domestic terrorists you believe it I'm
not a terrorist
but you know what there's great anger in
this country right now there's great
anger in this country never forget all
of this torment persecution and
oppression is not happening because of
anything we've done wrong right Donald
Trump as usual taking no responsibility
for anything but denying that he's a
terrorist in another really weird moment
Donald Trump said we have to keep
America gay which was another one of
these bizarre glitches where you can
tell that his brain and his mouth are
struggling to connect in anything that
we would call Common Sense uh
just take a listen to this great country
remember I was going to say it's going
to use an expression we have to keep our
country gate but but it's not I mean for
some reason it's just not great anymore
oh dear God we have to keep our country
gay
in all seriousness
it used to never be okay to say the
country isn't the best remember that
during the Iraq War for example during
which I started following and covering
politics
whenever those on the left would say
this really makes the US look bad this
invasion of Iraq because of 9 11 even
though they had nothing to do with each
other after making a case with faulty
intelligence
about weapons of mass destruction it
makes the country look terrible globally
and the polls showed it and Republicans
would say no that's unpatriotic you can
never criticize this country ever ever
ever and now it's completely mainstream
for republicans in the Trump Maga world
to say the country is no longer great it
used to be totally unacceptable to say
that then Donald Trump does his n-word
thing and you can tell the CR when Trump
asks the crowd do you know what the
n-word is they get really excited the
n-word you know what the n-word is
no no no no
Trump going no no no before the crowd
starts yelling it out and there were a
handful of black people there that who
would have would have probably not loved
that uh but Trump has to tell the crowd
no no no no no no no I'm talking about a
different N word n word you know what
the
you can see one one black guy over
Trump's left shoulder
sort of nodding a sigh of relief As
Trump says it's it's nuclear it's
nuclear everybody's sort of relaxed here
a very very strange moment
um and then uh Donald Trump again just
one of these things where it's not clear
whether his mind is scrambled or the
teleprompter is glitching you know
everything they do is disinformation
they say things and they keep saying I'm
saying I'm saying them as people start
even believing them or not believing
them there's not a lot of belief in this
place with all these thousands of people
going as far as the eye can see yeah
doesn't make any sense and then lastly
Donald Trump again playing the ominous
conspiracy music as he talks about how
bad things are in the country in this
particular case rambling about airports
being dirty I guess
we are a nation who has once revered
airports are dirty and a crowded mess
where you sit and wait for hours and
then are notified that the plane won't
leave and they have no idea when it will
a nation where ticket prices are through
the roof they don't have the pilots fly
the planes they don't want or seek
qualified air traffic controllers yeah
so anyway Trump knows very little about
what's going on in commercial Aviation
he's flown private for like 20 years
bonus clip bonus clip one of the
speakers before Trump
um mentioned Joe Biden and the crowd
immediately says lock him up remember
that's not due process that's not Law
and Order and
87
ARS agents to treat all of these Working
Families like tax Cheats by the way
remember
55 000 of the 87 000 are to replace
retiring agents it it's all really not
very scary when you know the facts come
on folks
[Music]
[ __ ] him up look
[Applause]
remember
it is not Law and Order to lock up
someone who hasn't even been charged
with a crime scary stuff and the
attendees are even scarier
at Donald Trump's rally over the weekend
in Wilmington North Carolina uh real
America's voice and right side
broadcasting and these right-wing
networks spoke to attendees a truly
classic moment Ed Henry and his co-host
speak to an attendee
trying to make the case that there's no
neo-nazis here right and the attendee
says listen I respect that neo-nazis
have a right to voice their opinion no
there's already articles that were
circulating that I was reading while he
was speaking when we were between things
and they're talking about the white
supremacists that were here did you see
any neo-nazis tonight not a single one
and uh if any were here you know I
respect people's privacy and and they're
they're right to voice their opinions
you don't agree with them I don't
necessarily agree with anybody I have I
don't necessarily I don't disagree with
the neo-nazis any more than I disagree
with anybody else I don't know I don't
believe right I think that this is
America we all have the opinion to
believe what we choose to believe but
dear God and the girlfriend looks
horrified absolutely horrified there's
no neo-nazis here right I don't think so
but I mean listen I respect the right to
privacy and the right to voice their
opinions but you disagree with them
right I don't know I don't particularly
disagree or agree with anybody what
complete and total backfire of the point
that they were trying to make here's a
guy interviewed before the speech who
said it is baffling to him that Biden
hasn't been impeached already that Biden
should be impeached for what he's done
um with with wasn't what he did with him
Afghanistan for one right
um which is the exact same thing Trump
would have done by the way us leaving
and not helping our our troops that are
still over there today right it's just
it it baffles my mind that a sitting
president can sleep at night
um knowing where he's done
this is a sad State of Affairs I have to
tell you and the interviewer there by
the way if she looks familiar that's one
of Trump's lawyers I mean it's
everything is just humiliating here's a
guy who believes Trump is a genius
I'm going to tell you why I support
president Trump yeah
he is a problem solver
in fact
I'm amazed of his genius yep
this guy can't even believe
how smart Trump is and the number of
problems that he has solved and then
lastly here is a woman
who
um is really confused about like rigged
elections I guess
I mean I think it starts from the
governor
I'll say it he's corrupt I don't think
he won there's no way right when Trump
and all Republicans won the down line
that he won in 2020 and I I don't care
who knows that but but um you know it's
just I feel like the state
has a lot of corruption yep so all the
Democrats that supposedly won in North
Carolina they didn't really win but the
Republicans clearly all did when when a
republican won they won fair and square
even if a lot of these folks were all on
the same ballot weaponized
disinformation and delusions weaponized
I don't know how you undo it okay one
other really quick note here
at Trump's previous rally in Ohio
we had this crazy thing where he starts
playing dramatic music while he talks
about how terrible things are in the U.S
and a lot of people in the crowd did a
one-finger salute and we didn't know
whether the idea was that it's a Nazi
salute except they're doing one finger
instead of the flat hand so it doesn't
look the same or whether it's a q Anon
salute because Q Anon has this WW1 you
know you guys know the thing okay so it
turns out it's a q Anon thing and the
Trump people
caught wind that it doesn't look great
for there to be Q Anon salutes happening
at Trump rallies so when they started
playing the dramatic conspiracy music at
Trump's latest rally in Wilmington North
Carolina security actually went through
the crowd uh telling people to put down
their hands it was very very interesting
and there's a couple of different posts
about this and this one you see
one guy with an American flag shirt with
the one finger thing and then you see
these security people going through the
crowd and it was widely reported that
they were telling all those people to
put their hands down to put their
fingers down that they didn't want to
see that we actually have a video of
this happening as well and this is what
Donald Trump is speaking and you see
some of these people with their fingers
up and then you start to see the
security people go through the crowd and
saying put your finger down put your
finger down you see these people go
through finger hands down hands down
hands down a bunch of them and then the
fingers come down they clearly have
realized that it doesn't look
particularly good for this to be
happening because it's a q Anon salute
now what's really funny is initially the
reaction was they're just saying we're
number one of course that doesn't make
any sense because they're saying we're
number one supposedly during the part of
the speech where Trump talks about how
terrible the country has become
so why would they decide to say we're
number one while Trump is talking about
our airports are terrible
a lot you know crime is rampant the
economy is terrible our leaders
everything's terrible oh yeah we're
number one that doesn't make any sense
so then now they're implicitly admitting
that it is not a salute that is just
we're number one because security goes
through the crowd when the fingers come
up and they say you got to put those
fingers down just a little note for
everybody on that particular issue
it was never the truth that they
believed that they were just saying
we're number one ever ever it's a q Anon
salute it looks bad and now they're
having their literal Brown Shirts it's
an extra security force that wears Brown
Shirts go through the crowd and say put
the fingers down these rallies have
become completely dystopian
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right let's get into a couple other
uh different things there's a clip
that's been making the rounds from a
republican Town Hall Republicans in the
house have been doing this commitment to
America agenda rollout town halls and
it's all weird and they're trying to
pretend like they care about policy
again but the policy is all just
cultural issues and random nonsense so
at this event and House minority leader
Congressman Kevin McCarthy was at this
event a woman gets up you know a
concerned mom in the audience the the a
prototypical concerned mom and she lists
a whole bunch of things that she
believes are really Marxism and in that
list she includes not bullying people
not bullying people is Marxism according
to this Republican mom supposedly and
this is a there is so much behind this
that I want to talk about it but first
let's take a look at the clip and you'll
notice if you're watching that as she
talks about this Kevin McCarthy kind of
nods along like this makes sense there
are many other public education issues
concerning parents like myself
the slow creep of critical race Theory
diversity equity and inclusion right
gender identity and allowing biological
boys to enter girls spaces and sports
now we have SEL which is social
emotional learning
it's indoctrination disguises promo
programs like kindness initiatives or
anti-bullying programs anti-bullying
amps or diversity projects
these are all marks of style programs
targeting our children yeah
so listen there there's a lot going on
here and there's many many many layers
now at the most superficial level
if you've watched the Trump rally it
does kind of seem like Republicans are
okay with bullying that I don't know
that I would say pro-bullying maybe so
but they're at least okay with it you
know Trump would get him the hell out of
here Trump's saying to people in the
crowd he'll pay their legal bills if
they beat the crap out of protesters at
the rallies making fun of the disabled
reporter I mean there's bullying of All
Sorts never mind this entire like beta
male type stuff that they subscribe to
so one part of it is they do seem to buy
into this kind of strict father morality
idea that getting knocked around a
little bit getting bullied whatever it
builds character it toughens you up it
makes people strong or whatever the case
maybe rather than you know it can really
kind of Scar people for life and ruin
their lives irreparably in some cases so
that that's one part of it which is they
actually do seem to sort of be okay with
bullying to some degree number one
number two
this is part of the growing movement
that empathy is bad empathy is not
desirable empathy is uh feminine in some
way or beta or whatever and that's been
increasingly a part of Republican
ideology for a long time facts don't
care about your feelings it's a popular
line listen things just are what they
are you got to call things what they are
you got to call a man a man no matter
what you've got to call you know these
are the phrases that they love to use
where empathy is a bad thing now
I don't know that they're unable to be
empathetic because we do anecdotally
hear about these stories where you know
homophobic member of Congress for 20
years turns out they've got a lesbian
daughter or you know a gay
um nephew or something like that and all
of a sudden they they change their view
so in those cases we say it's really sad
that it took something like that to get
them to change their views but they were
at least able to so maybe maybe it's not
just about an inability to feel empathy
but then we have all of these studies
about the differences between what end
up being Republican brains or Democratic
brains and we see on the Republican side
larger fear centers uh less empathy Etc
now I think one of the things that can
be deceptive about that is
it's not about
Republican and Democratic brains per se
it's more about
who's more fear oriented
who's more anger oriented who's more
discussed oriented they end up being on
the political right which in the United
States pushes you towards the Republican
party and if you consider that maybe
there is some kind of neurological or
biological explanation here but then the
Counterpoint to that is sometimes when
they experience something themselves
their views do change what I don't like
is that this is all kind of a cover for
the fact that they're mad that in some
circles it's not seen as acceptable to
openly bully people who are in some way
different than the majority
it's not okay in some places anymore
thankfully to openly bully LGBT people a
lot of them don't like that minorities
in many cases they would still they they
like the uh idea of the days where it
was okay to more openly bully or poorly
treat minorities and and now they're
upset it's considered woke that you
can't do that anymore that's at the Crux
of all of this stuff and absent policy
because the Republican party has given
up on policy that when's the last time
you heard a serious discussion
involving Republicans about what tax
rates should be
they don't do it anymore
it's gone they're just not doing it
anymore when is the last time they
genuinely talked productively about uh
American foreign policy other than just
criticizing Biden because he both didn't
do enough and did too much by spending
too much money when it comes to Ukraine
they don't even pretend to be about
policy anymore this new movement where
this mom concerned mom spoke it's them
pretending to care about policy again
even though they clearly don't and it's
just about bemoaning the fact that they
can't treat all the same people horribly
that they used to treat horribly truly
disgusting stuff hey this is sort of uh
sort of exciting
the David pakman show is now within
Striking Distance of 1.5
million YouTube subscribers thank your
lucky stars every day you're not Dave
Pacman well hold on a second because
things are turning up this is actually a
really great thing for us there are very
few Progressive YouTube channels like
ours that are at the 1.5 million
subscriber level in fact I it's under
four
um we are extraordinarily close to this
Milestone and what we've started doing
is putting together a sort of calendar
of interesting things that will happen
the sooner we achieve this goal now if
we do nothing nothing at all just like
let subscribers climb naturally
we are slated to hit 1.5 million on
November 4th so we would make it before
election day which was originally my
goal but on a recent stream I floated
the question well
what might we be able to do to get
people interested in getting us there
more quickly and people have started to
contact me saying David here's what I'm
willing to do if you get to the goal by
x-state or by why date so we're I think
this is actually going to be really
really fun so if you have an idea of
something you would like to contribute
if we move the date up just email info
davidpackman.com so let me give you some
examples if we move the date up from
November 4th to October 21st and by move
it up it just means people subscribe
that's all it means just hit subscribe
and then it'll happen sooner if we do it
by October 21st this is unbelievable our
viewer Kurt has agreed to get a
panoramic back tattoo of Mount Rushmore
with five faces on it this is the tattoo
Biden Obama
Clinton
FDR and my face now I don't really know
how I feel about someone getting my face
tattooed on them it's a little weird to
be perfectly Frank but it sounds
interesting and Kurt is willing to get
that tattoo
if we move the date up to October 21st
okay if we move it all the way up to
October 5th which by the way we're 5 000
subscribers away it's completely
plausible that we do that we could do
that in two days if we if we really
buckle down if we make it to 1.5 million
by October 5 and from Utah suggested
that I buy or rent a unicycle and film
myself riding it down the street that's
fine I will do that I will buy I will
find a unicycle one way or another if we
make it to 1.5 million by October 5 and
I will ride it down the street and then
one of our viewers uh s Perez during our
recent stream said David if you make it
to 1.5 million by Yom Kippur uh one of
the Jewish High holidays which is
October 4th I should do the Yom Kippur
fast now as a non-religious Jew I have
never done the fast it's just I believe
it's a sunset to Sunset fast
I'm willing to do it and I will live
blog the fasting and how uh how it is
okay so that's if we make it by October
4th now the way I'm doing it is because
we don't want to just like have to pick
one of these things if we make it to 1.5
million by any of these dates
all of the things promised from that
date on should happen right so if we do
it on October 4th I will do the Yom
Kippur fast and I will ride the unicycle
and hopefully Kurt will get the
panoramic back tattoo okay so my request
to you is two very simple things one
subscribe to the YouTube channel that's
it it's free it costs you nothing just
subscribe to the YouTube channel and
number two if you're willing to do
something with our calendar here oh and
uh we're seeing the numbers shift in
real time if you're willing to add
something to the calendar email info
davidpackman.com let me know what it is
and we will get it on the wackiness
calendar all right very very good we
have a voicemail number that number is
2192 David P here is a really good
question that many of you have written
in with about the telepathic
declassification of documents take a
listen
hey David enjoy the show hey um what
would happen if Biden thought about
reclassifying the documents right uh
he's considering president he can do
that right have fun yeah no it's I get
that it's a joke but it's absolutely a
real thing
if Trump can think about documents and
declassify them then Biden can think
about documents and classify them and
thus it becomes completely uh um uh
indefeasible one way or the other
because no matter what at any point any
document could be classified or
Declassified based on what the current
president has thought about it's absurd
these people are nuts Guys these people
the telepathic declassification give me
a break it's pathetic we have a great
bonus show for you today Liz Cheney
Republican congresswoman Liz Cheney
outgoing because she was defeated in her
Republican primary in Wyoming Liz Cheney
says that if Trump is the nominee in
2024
she will leave the Republican Party
and she will campaign for Democrats
what yes we will discuss that on today's
bonus show secondly 80 percent of
American voters want Congress to enact
National paid family leave and this is
another one of these examples where we
supposedly have the will of the people
reflected in the elected officials that
are voted on by the pop the general
public and yet the general public is
very far to the left
of our elected officials and this is
another issue where that is the case and
thirdly everything going terribly for
Rudy Giuliani who has now been ordered
to pay his ex-wife 225 thousand dollars
or face jail time Rudy is claiming that
as a result of all of this legal trouble
in which he finds himself he doesn't
have the money he says he's uh
increasingly without money
is that even true we don't know we'll
talk about it and more on today's bonus
show you can sign up at joinpakman.com
to get instant access to the bonus show
we will see you then or otherwise right
back here tomorrow Michael Cohen
scheduled to join us later this week
about his new book I do want to hear
from him about some of these latest you
know what when the pictures came out of
Trump's Mar-A-Lago I thought Michael
Cohen would know what does Trump's
office normally look like is it normally
the mess that it appeared to be in the
pictures I have so many things to talk
to him about he has a super interesting
new book that'll be later this week but
for now sign up at joinpathman.com and
we'll see you back here on the podcast
tomorrow
foreign